for our our most recent Jackass movie
they brought in a big water tank and
there was this mechanism to capture
farts completely underwater so it'd be a
bubble of of air but it's it's fart air
right and and bring in uh torch to light
it under water now I could not believe
the blast that that caused well so the
fart bubble is being com is completely
surrounded by water which is much denser
than the air itself and so any explosion
is a high temperature spot that wrap
because of the high temperature rapidly
expands the air around it and it's the
expanding air that we think of as the
explosion in this case you have rapidly
expanding bubble but the bubble has its
size right if you try to make that
bubble any bigger instantly
what's the water gonna do the water is
not going to compress it has to fly out
of the way right